[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain an american science
fiction thriller film called awake
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
jill adams is a former u.s army medic
and a recovering alcoholic she works as
a security guard in a local medical
college to raise her kids noah and
matilda
at the beginning of the movie she enters
the hospital at night and uses her
privileges to sneak into the research
lab she then steals some medicine and
sells them to a local drug dealer the
next morning after the adventurous
morning jill goes to her mother doris's
house to pick up her children because of
jill's past with drug abuse noah and
matilda are currently under doris's
custody by law matilda is delighted to
meet her mother but noah like a typical
teenager seems grumpy once noah gets
over puberty he'll think it's cool that
his mom is an addict and a thief doris
sees them off but asks jill to bring the
kids home by seven as they drive the car
swerves and stops by the side of the
road the mother asks her kids if they
are okay but before they can reply a car
hits them and sends them flying into a
lake the family struggles to get out of
the flooding vehicle jill and noah
somehow manage to swim up but notice
that matilda is nowhere to be seen to
their relief a policeman has saved her
and has brought her to shore jill is
hurt so the policeman suggests she go to
the hospital he reveals that the entire
city is going through a power crisis and
everything that works on electricity or
gas is malfunctioning all the vehicles
in the city have stopped working out of
the blue which has caused several
accidents everywhere jill and the kids
rushed to the hospital only to see that
it is packed because of cases of
accidents no one knows what caused the
power loss or when it is going to come
back but the people at the hospital
speculate that they might be at war or
are being attacked by a terrorist
organization or perhaps the y2k bug was
just late to the party after all as the
family waits for someone to attend to
them they witnessed two patients who
were in a coma waking up at the same
time they come back home and stay at
doris's for the night noah and jill
cannot fall asleep so they look at the
stars through the window and notice
satellites moving at high speed the
following morning jill cycles to work
even though it is still pretty dark
everyone in the neighborhood is awake
she is confused because normally the
streets are empty at this time of the
day before going to work she goes to her
drug dealer who tells her that he can
double the price on any pills she can
provide as the sales are skyrocketing
due to the power loss at work jill takes
the risk and tries stealing medicine in
broad daylight she is caught by the
college's chief dr murphy who walks into
the room with two soldiers to jill's
surprise the last thing they care about
is her stealing the medicine they are
preoccupied with finding the cause of
the power loss dr murphy remembers that
jill used to be a medic so she asks her
to join the survivor's hub established
to research the power loss jill declines
the offer wanting to be with her kids
instead an employee from the college
named brian tells jill that no one in
the city has been able to fall asleep
for the last 48 hours they are unsure
what is causing it but it is almost as
if the power loss eradicated humans
ability to fall asleep brian explains
the severity of the situation claiming
that people will soon suffer from the
symptoms of sleep deprivation and if
this goes on for long enough everyone
will lose their minds plus freddy
krueger will be out of work jill doesn't
believe him because matilda slept
peacefully the entire night and was fast
asleep when she left for work brian is
shocked because the only known person
who has slept in the past 48 hours is an
old woman with heart disease the doctors
have been studying her symptoms in the
hopes of finding a cure for the
condition jill realizes that matilda and
the woman are the only exceptions in the
entire city brian asks jill to take
matilda to the hub to help the doctors
but jill declines fearing the
experiments that the doctors will
perform on her daughter following that
she rushes home to look for matilda but
finds out that she is in the church with
doris everyone at the church has been
told that matilda can still sleep the
pastor gives a sermon about matilda
being a beacon of hope now the
extremists present in the church want to
sacrifice her in the hopes of getting
their sleep back back home jill senses
that matilda might be in great danger if
people find out she can sleep so she
packs up a bag of necessities deciding
to run away from society she and noah
make their way to the church and brian
tags along on their way they witness
several robberies taking place they also
come across the dead body of a police
officer in an alleyway people have
already started going insane because of
sleep deprivation jill finally reaches
the church and hears the people discuss
if they should sacrifice matilda brian
tries to convince the people to let her
go to the hob and help the scientists
develop a cure but a police officer who
is in favor of sacrificing her shoots
him dead everyone panics and starts
running around amidst the chaos jill
manages to get her children and the
three run to a nearby forest noah
convinces jill to go to the hub because
if he and jill die in a few days people
will kill matilda while discussing their
next move jill realizes that some old
models of cars must still be working so
they go to a nearby garage to find one
noah and matilda hide outside as jill
carefully walks inside the garage she
notices two thugs have looted the place
and are already planning to claim all
the cars as their own jill walks further
inside and manages to get the keys all
while staying hidden after finding a car
that works they start their journey to
the hub
a while later matilda sleeps in the back
of the car given the circumstances noah
is astounded by his sister's ability to
sleep
never underestimate the power of a
teenager they stop the vehicle when they
see an accident in the middle of the
street jill walks closer and notices the
thugs from earlier have been killed in
an accident she simply takes their gun
and continues the journey a while later
they come across a bunch of naked people
presumably from a cult standing in the
middle of the road to jill's relief they
make room for the car to pass
they were just there for the youtube
thumbnails the family then reaches a
secluded library and decides to take a
rest jill teaches matilda to shoot a gun
claiming that she will need it after
jill and noah die of sleep deprivation
the thought of being alone terrifies
matilda
later she is sleeping outside in the car
while noah and jill are trying to locate
the hub on a map
several prisoners are let free from a
nearby prison because of the crisis a
prisoner named dodge finds the car and
drives away with matilda still inside of
it when the other two come outside they
are surprised to see that matilda is
missing to add to their problems the
other prisoners surround them asking
noah to come over
jill runs out of bullets and the
criminals are about to capture them when
dodge drives the car back to the library
he saves jill and noah and drives away
moments later they stop near the plane
wreckage dodge finds several clothes and
other necessities in the wreckage after
which they head north to the hub at
night jill teaches matilda to drive to
prepare her for the possibility of
living alone while they are at it they
notice people's dead bodies hanging
upside down by the side of the road jill
hurriedly tries to drive away but the
maniacs outside break the car's window
and grab them through it as they
struggle to stay inside matilda presses
the gas and they somehow manage to drive
away
some hours later they finally reach the
hub jill and the kids hand the car over
to dodge so he can drive to his hometown
to meet his family he offers to stick
around to help them but they decline
jill then keeps noah and matilda hidden
in a house because after everything that
happened on the way she wants to make
sure the hub is safe for her children
the sleep deprivation is starting to get
to her she approaches the hub while
hiding under a bridge she finds out that
the army protecting the hub is surviving
on medicine but slowly they are also
turning violent
jill disguises herself as a lab worker
and meets the old woman who is the only
person that can sleep other than matilda
jill wants her to raise matilda since
only she has a possibility of surviving
but the woman is too sick and old to
understand her request she reveals that
she was supposed to be dead last month
but is somehow still living just then dr
murphy enters the room and sees them
talking
jill claims that she is there to help
murphy is also visibly affected by the
lack of sleep she says that the doctors
have found a drug that helps the
sleep-deprived brain function better for
a short period of time but it also harms
the brain if that drug isn't cocaine i
will eat my hat jill returns to the
house and sees that dodge noah and
matilda have been found by the soldiers
dodge had come back to help them but now
all of them are at gunpoint to save
their life matilda tearfully admits that
she can sleep the soldiers then take her
to their lab
the researcher dr katz exposes her to an
anesthetic gas and is surprised to see
that she can actually sleep jill has now
lost her rationality because of sleep
deprivation and exhaustion murphy asks
her questions about matilda but she can
hardly form a sentence following that
the old lady goes into cardiac arrest
and passes away despite the doctor's
efforts to save her now the fate of
humanity is in matilda's hands dodge is
taken as a guard and is given stimulants
to help with exhaustion meanwhile jill
experiences hallucinations where she
sees noah trying to kill her she comes
back to her senses when a soldier takes
noah away who is beside her the whole
time as time passes everyone at the hub
including the medical staff and the
soldiers start to lose their minds they
experience hallucinations and shoot
everyone around them one of the soldiers
calls jail sandra and tries to kill her
moments later she shoots herself dead
then they start killing each other jill
rushes to save matilda but murphy stops
her some seconds later she dies because
of the stimulants dr katz has given her
jill finally frees matilda and they run
to save noah noah on the other hand is
hallucinating as well he touches an
electric wire believing it to be a fish
and gets electrocuted in the process
jill and matilda try their best to save
him but to no avail the following
morning dead bodies are scattered all
around the establishment everyone has
died except for matilda and jill yet
jill is not in her right mind and is
about to pass out any time suddenly noah
wakes up alive and well the two are
surprised and overjoyed to have him back
they noticed that noah seems to have
come back from a deep sleep and is now
normal matilda registers that noah could
sleep because he temporarily died last
night like she did when she drowned in
the lake in an attempt to save their
mother the kids bring her to a nearby
lake they push her into the water
waiting for her to stop moving when she
goes limp they bring her out and try to
revive her the movie ends as the kids
perform cpr on their mother geez i hope
their theory was correct
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching